today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
it's great to be back from vacation and
i will talk about what i did
on the bonus show but we have to jump
right into it we learned at the start of
this weekend that supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg passed away
at the age of 87 and this has
simultaneously
set off a nationwide
really a global mourning period for one
of the
premier progressive jurists a
truly remarkable legal mind whose legal
acumen
was surpassed maybe only by her wit
and sense of humor and it has set off a
political firestorm
immediately refreshing the battle
from the last year of barack obama's
presidency
over the nomination of merrick garland
then to replace
the late supreme court justice antonin
scalia that was a nomination remember
which republicans led by mitch mcconnell
successfully blocked and we're going to
be talking about
all of it now first of all is the
personal i'm going to focus on the
political
but ruth bader ginsburg's personal story
is an incredible one
born in brooklyn at a time when the
legal world
was a big uphill battle not just for
women but for
jewish women a tiny woman barely five
feet tall
ultimately becoming the second
woman ever to be on the supreme court
after sandra day o'connor's retirement
in 2006
rbg was the only woman on the supreme
court
a cultural icon well into her 80s
really a rock star in the political in
the social in the cultural world
there's no way to say all of the things
that could be said
about ruth bader ginsburg now there is a
criticism
that she should have retired when she
was
say 82 years old already with some
health problems
to ensure that barack obama
would have gotten a clean chance to
choose her replacement
to preempt the situation we now see
and that is a fair criticism and it's in
the past
and there's nothing we can do about it
now
and so what is the story now well the
story now
is there are 45ish days remaining
maybe 45 exactly until an election
in which donald trump might lose and
donald trump and republicans most
republicans have shown that they are
committed to filling this seat and
filling it as soon as possible
we're going to talk about who might opt
out of that
but it is of course a huge double
standard in 2016 when barack obama was
in his last
year republicans said let the people
have a say
let the people vote before we fill this
seat and indeed they won on that
they held the seat they refused to give
barack obama's nominee merrick garland
confirmation hearings and ultimately
donald trump filled that seat a year
later with neil gorsuch to replace
antonin scalia and now seemingly the
same situation
republicans are saying we have a
constitutional duty to fill this seat
without delay
and they are going to try now mitch
mcconnell's explanation is well
it's not really the same situation
because back in 2016
it was opposite parties in the senate
and white house
it was barack obama a democrat and
republicans controlling the senate
it's different now because it's
republicans
controlling the senate with a republican
president
that is their argument it's a ridiculous
argument
it is a double standard but it doesn't
matter what matters is are they going to
be able to do it
and we're going to talk about that in a
moment the legacy of ruth bader ginsburg
is one that will be studied hopefully
for a very long time
it's an inspirational story not just
to young women about someone who really
uh pushed the boundaries of what society
uh considered to be the appropriate or
or or valid roles of women in society
really uh an extraordinary woman an
extraordinary career
and again a a cultural and legal
icon well into her 80s
we will miss her her legacy and now the
question
is what will become of that seat and
that's what we're going to talk about
next we'll talk about process
and we'll talk about political
implications so okay
uh first is process will republicans be
able to confirm a justice
to replace ruth bader ginsburg before
the election on november 3rd
before the january 20th inauguration
time
wise 45 days which is what we have
roughly remaining between now and the
november 3rd election
that's very fast typically it takes
about 70 days
from nomination to confirmation for a
supreme court justice so
it would be very tough to do it in the
45 days before the election
but it could happen donald trump
reportedly going to nominate a
replacement for ruth bader ginsburg
this week the bigger question to me
is the lame duck period eve it i don't
know that they need to necessarily do it
before the election
because i believe that even if joe biden
were to win
they will have the time and potentially
the ability potentially the power
potentially the support
to install a replacement for ruth bader
ginsburg
during the interim period the lame duck
period between november
3rd 4th and january 20th now do they
have the votes you need 51 votes
to confirm a supreme court justice or
you need 50 votes
plus the tie-breaking vote from the vice
president which they would have
in mike pence for sure republicans have
a political situation to contend with
because republicans are defending
25 of the 38 senate seats that are on
the ballot
many of their more vulnerable members
have been eager to get back home get out
of uh
dc expected to to be around mid-october
i forget the exact date
and campaign and that would shorten the
pre-election period it's not really 45
days it's more like 30 or 35 days
because 30 really maybe even 25
because they are planning to end this
session in mid-october now some of those
senators might realize
not only that they need to get back and
campaign
because their seats are at risk but that
pushing forward on this before the
election could actually be bad for their
re-election the balance right now
in the senate is 53 republicans and 47
democrats that's 45 democrats plus two
independents angus king and bernie
sanders who caucus with democrats so
what they need those of us what we need
who oppose uh donald trump getting to
replace rbg
is we need four republican senators to
say no
now very early there was this suspicion
or there were rumors that mitt romney
wasn't going to do this before the
inauguration
that was almost immediately refuted by
campaign staff now
maybe romney wouldn't do it we don't
know yet the early claims that
were made were merely rumors
we then heard from alaska republican
senator
lisa murkowski who put out a very
carefully worded statement saying that
quote i did not support
taking up a nomination eight months
before the 2016 election to fill the
vacancy created
by the passing of justice scalia we are
now
even closer to the 2020 election less
than two months out
and i believe the same standard must
apply so
certainly lisa murkowski is a no before
the election but there is nothing here
and this is why you have to look at the
wording
there's nothing here that says if trump
loses
she may still go forward with a vote to
confirm
during what would be a lame duck period
for donald trump
that's really the question mark
otherwise we really aren't sure
we can speculate susan collins okay
maybe she wouldn't go for it
before the election but what about
during the lame duck period
potential lame duck period cory gardner
in colorado
he might realize this could be very bad
for his re-election
but maybe during the lame duck period we
don't know maybe martha mcsally who's
down
to mark kelly in arizona
we just don't know now
we have to look at the hypocrisy and the
reason i'm kind of hesitating is
they don't care they don't care but yes
they are hypocrites
look at some of these quotes from and
2018
senator ted cruz in 2016 it has been 80
years
since the supreme court vacancy was
nominated and confirmed in
an election year there is a long
tradition
that you don't do this in an election
year hypocrite
lindsey graham in 2018 if an opening
comes
in the last year of president trump's
term and the primary process has started
we'll wait to the next election marco
rubio
i don't think we should be moving on a
nominee in the last
year of this president's term i would
say that
if it was a republican president well
we're waiting marco
tom tillis from north carolina
republican
the campaign is already underway it is
essential to the institution of the
senate
and to the very health of our republic
to not launch our nation
into a partisan divisive confirmation
battle
during the very same time the american
people
are casting their ballots to elect our
next president now i could go
on and on with more and more of these
but ultimately
trumpists have not punished republicans
for heinous
hypocrisy and i have no reason to
believe that they will
this time maybe some individual races
could be affected
but let's circle back around is there
anything
positive here because it seems like this
is a disaster for america
giving trump the opportunity to ruin
things not just for four years
not merely for eight years but for
decades the one thing that is very clear
to me
is that this has the possibility to
hugely energize democratic voters
including left-leaning centrists
anti-trump
moderates and even many of the never
biden left-wingers
since friday night at 8 pm eastern which
is when the world
learned of the passing of ruth bader
ginsburg small-dollar donations have
exploded
to democrats 100 million dollars
were donated in the 40 or so hours
following the death
of ruth bader ginsburg people are
reacting
people are donating to biden people are
donating to democrats nationally and i
do believe this will increase
voter turnout including early voting
which we are already seeing
what can we control here okay we can't
make republicans be consistent
we can't make republicans stop being
hypocrites we can't make
republicans good moral people we can't
control trump
but we can vote and we can lobby and we
can donate and we can phone bank and we
can call our senators let's focus on
what we can do
let me know on twitter what do you
expect to see
with this open seat i'm on twitter at d
pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store if you're a guy looking for
the perfect way
to refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make is in a high
quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches
from top quality materials and they just
look great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon
automatic collection the one i got is in
mesh matte black
and i love it it's simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about
anything i'm wearing and i've gotten a
ton of compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay this story is one of those stories
where you really have to look at the
details to know
what what is the story is this a big
story or not
the the story is that democratic vice
presidential nominee kamala harris has
now confirmed that if she and joe biden
are elected
that they would decriminalize the use of
marijuana at the federal level now
everybody went crazy for different
reasons kamala harris
outlined at an event through facebook
live with abc
the broad strokes of the proposal and it
includes
among other things which i will get to
full federal
decriminalization of the use of
marijuana
you had some people on the right who are
just furious who say
decriminalizing marijuana use is the
first step to anarchy
it's the first step to rampant out of
control addiction and chaos everywhere
biden must be stopped
and then you have people on the left who
are saying this is so lame
this is so centrist decriminalized use
we must legalize use we must
decriminalize small-scale dealing of
marijuana
this is way too right-wing for me so
what's the truth
the truth is one that most people don't
want to accept
which is progress typically comes in
steps i believe
we need full legalization of use
regulate it
tax it selling it on the street becomes
sort of like selling illegal cigarettes
and you deal with it like a health issue
instead of a criminal issue when you
have substance abuse
issues without question though
a federal decriminalization would be a
big deal
but it would just be one step with
another four years of trump
we get nothing we just get nothing
simply nothing period
now there are also people mad that
kamala flip-flopped kamala used to be
against legalization and
decriminalization
10 years ago well she's changed her view
and we should applaud that
in other words there are lots of elected
officials who eventually came around
to better positions and they shouldn't
be shamed for that
some what some people call flip-flopping
sometimes is flip-flopping
merely for for sort of political
posturing purposes
but sometimes you evolve because you
actually get more information or you
mature
you come around to the right point of
view so
in 2019 she sponsored legislation which
would federally deschedule
cannabis uh that would would be a great
thing to do
and uh overall we should be glad that
she changed her mind
now let's be real there's a major gap
between decriminalization and
legalization if you
legalize cannabis you can uh
regulate it similar to alcohol and
tobacco
you can tax it to decriminalize cannabis
merely removes criminal sanctions when
you
offend or break the law cannabis could
remain
illegal possession above a certain
amount
could result in civil fines or drug
education or treatment instead of
criminal prosecution so it is not a
panacea it is not the end point
but it is a step forward joe biden
by the way wouldn't just federally
federally decriminalize but according to
his website would
also expunge prior cannabis use
convictions
that's a good thing that gets a bunch of
people cleared
it's certainly not going to impact
low-level dealers who are sitting in
prison and we need to deal with that
but it is a step forward joe biden also
supports
the legalization of medical cannabis at
the federal level
but again would leave decisions about
adult
recreational use up to the states
so listen um this is one of those times
where we
we just have to be very real and
pragmatic if biden
gets to do what is on his platform it
would be the most progressive federal
cannabis policy
in the history of a sitting president
period i get
that we want to do more i get that many
of us feel that it's 2020
and this is not enough and we need to be
catching up to other countries that have
dealt with this
uh in in more progressive ways already
but if
biden gets in and he does this stuff
the u.s would be as progressive at as it
has ever been
when it comes to the regulation of
cannabis
if they do this it will lead to
more legalization in more states for
sure
there will be states who if they see
decriminalized federally
expunging convictions so on and so forth
there will be states that maybe right
now or 53 to 47
against legalization that will say look
at look what's happening federally
let's do it you know other states have
done it massachusetts did it colorado et
cetera
this will be a major step forward and of
course we want more but let's not miss
the forest for the trees and much like
with healthcare
is biden's idea perfect of course not
does biden's
platform on healthcare fix all of the
problems we've identified
not even close but if trump got his way
30 million people would lose coverage
okay let's not miss the forest for the
trees we're going to have
more on this on our instagram account
follow us there at david pakman show
follow me on instagram
david.pakman for pictures from my
vacation
which i will talk about on today's bonus
show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay so i'm going to try to get us
caught up on some of the donald trump
events of the last 72 to 96 hours there
was a lot of craziness during the tail
end of our vacation donald trump
continuing to hold rallies as if there
were no pandemic often with
a hundreds or thousands of people many
without masks mostly without masks
sometimes the people on stage behind
trump
do have to put masks on but the rallies
range
from horrifying to authoritarian to
dystopian to perverse and everything in
between
there were notable rallies in the past
few days
in north carolina minnesota and nevada
i'm going to highlight different things
in different clips
notably the north carolina rally on
saturday which is where we will start
this was post the death of ruth bader
ginsburg
the country learned of the death of ruth
bader ginsburg during trump's friday
night rally which i will get to
this rally you will see a whole bunch of
nonsense related to rbg
so let's go through the key moments
trump having notable problems speaking
during this one even worse than the ones
earlier in the weekend
here is donald trump who has had a
renewed focus on the moon and
mars lately saying that you the united
states will be the first station
to put an astronaut on nars with an end
take a look
we'll land the first woman on the moon
and the united states will be the first
nation
to land an astronaut on nars
on mars we have trump actually
just really struggling to put together a
sentence a number of verbal glitches at
this one
here is trump's short circuiting on the
word sanctity
just really odd almost like he choked on
his tongue
he will defend the dignity of work and
we will defend the sanctity
the sanctity of life then trump
struggling with nobel peace prize
several times
calling it the nobel priests prize and
then getting all mixed up
and and discombobulated not clear-headed
i got the nobel priest first nomination
a peace prize nobel nomination
and then before we move into the meat of
it here he is
saying his own name wrong when you say
your own name wrong
that is another level referring to don
donald trump donald trump
okay that was the first little time then
he went donald trump
donald trump i love donald trump but
yeah
so not going well from the standpoint of
verbal
one of the sickest moments trump having
his supporters
vote by yelling as to whether they would
prefer
that he replaced ruth bader ginsburg
with a man
versus a woman it's almost like a
deleted
scene from saturday night live where
they said now this is
too stupid well it's reality
so women and men ready
would you rather have a woman on the
super supreme court or would you rather
have a man ready
a woman or a man so would you rather
have me choose
this very scientific poll actually it's
a lot more accurate than these polls
that interview like
97 people have been interviewed then you
know they charge you a million dollars
and they probably don't interview the
people they sit behind their desk and
just say
would you rather have a woman
on the supreme court yes woman yes
tom tiller says yes so would you rather
win or would you rather have a man on
the supreme court
everything is a game everything is a
joke a contest it's unserious
in some way with donald trump still on
ruth bader ginsburg
early in the rally donald trump fed the
line to the crowd
fill that seat kind of telling them it
didn't naturally surface donald trump
telling the crowd
the chant now is fill that seat and then
trump
here uh um in in announcing that he will
uh in saying that he will announce ruth
bader ginsburg's
replacement this week or potential
replacement the crowd getting going with
phil that
seat and by the way we have plenty of
time there's a lot of time you know
you're talking about
you're talking about january 20th right
here's a video of donald trump telling
one of those
inane stories about people referring to
him as sir
and what's notable about this one is
that the crowd is almost completely
silent trump's going on and on
the crowd not even remotely keyed into
what the hell trump is talking about
check it out an almost completely silent
crowd the crowd is so quiet
when one person reacts when one person
laughs
you hear them you hear that stand out
take a look
5.7 billion sir i said that's a lot of
money it's actually two planes you know
air force one is two planes i'll give
you a little they're going to say that's
classified information well they've been
flying around with two planes for 30
years
so i assume somebody though and our air
force one is 31 years old right so you
know look it's time
a lot of the arab sheep sheik's come in
i see they're playing they have a brand
new one i said what do we have 31 years
and we're protecting them why the hell
don't we have a new one
so i said so they finally had it 31
years old the new one's totally
different 7 47
it's much longer bigger wingspan much
more beautiful you know it's modern it's
beautiful
5.7 so i said to the head of boeing nice
guy dennis
this was before they had their
difficulty which is terrible what
happened to him but
that went on for a few minutes and
really relatable right like
billionaire president complains that
arab sheiks have much
nicer newer private airplanes than he
gets to fly around in really a man of
the people
then trump sort of laughed about how
msnbc reporter ali velshi was actually
hit by rubber bullets while covering
protests refers to him as a cnn reporter
details don't matter ali velshi's
actually with msnbc
trump again with a completely silent
crowd behind him
no first grade teacher has ever been
able to accomplish this
trump gets a huge crowd of people uh
with low attention spans to actually sit
completely quietly they lined up they
went down there was no social distancing
in between
these great tough guys there was no
social
distancing tom tillis they went down and
they had but like 250 000 outfits they
had more crap in their helmet with
night goggles and these guys were sort
of you know wise guys right
shouting at him screaming at him they
were screaming at the wrong people they
went down they never had to stop it was
just forward
it all ended it all ended in minneapolis
it took
you all sort what a half an hour
remember they hit the
cnn reporter in the knee he went down
alive elsie he said
this is a friendly protest it's
wonderful to see
such a behind him it was all fire for
black
it looked like berlin during the war
this is a friendly what are they doing
how does that help to be
like that how does that help we're
joined tonight and then
donald trump rehabbing this conspiracy
theory
that joe biden got some kind of upper
before his debate with bernie which is
hilarious because trump's the one that
always seems to either be on uppers or
downers
depending on the day take a look at that
no but don't underestimate look he's
been doing this for 47 years
and i got a debate coming up with this
guy
no it's true you never know you never
know
they gave him a big fat shot in the ass
and he comes out
and for two hours he's better than ever
before
the problem is what happens after that
now we're gonna ask for a drug test we
are i'd like to have a drug test
both of us i'll take it he'll take
because i watched him in the debates
with uh you know with all those people
those democrats
trump initially was speculating was
biden maybe
on something trump has now moved on with
no more evidence mind you
trump has moved on to saying biden got a
shot of something which improved his
performance during the debate
trump still seems to think that
coronavirus testing
causes illness which is just wacky take
a look at this
billion people we are up 50 million
tests
more than india in fact we're about to
crack
100 million tests and when you test
then you have does this make sense and
you have cases so we do all this testing
and i come home and i turn on
nbc news it is so it is so
bad i think
nbc that's
not only msdnc i think nbc
with lester holt is another beauty hi
lester
and then it got really weird i spent a
while on this clip
i don't know what trump is talking about
trump seems to say that
he would give himself a d as a grade
on his coronavirus response he never
explains why and it almost becomes
unclear whether trump thinks
a d is a good grade or a bad grade it's
a very strange clip
they stopped it from going into the rest
of china should have been stopped in
china to defeat the china virus we
launched the largest
industrial mobilization since world war
ii
somebody said what grade would you give
yourself i said a plus
but i would give myself a d i would say
i would give myself and my whole group
because mike pence is great mike pence
really was
he worked so hard and it's unfair he
worked so hard the ventilators the
vaccines
the therapeutics now we have like does
trump know
a d isn't good it's just complete and
utter nonsense
and then finally in this dystopian event
donald trump actually admits he's
counting on the courts
to play a role in him winning
re-election on november 3rd take a look
at this
what we're going to have a victory
on november 3rd the likes of which
you've never seen
now we're counting on the federal court
system to make it so that we can
actually have an evening where we know
who wins
okay not where the votes are going to be
counted a week later or two weeks later
but in just three and a half years under
my administration we've secured
america's borders
rebuilt the awesome power of the u.s
military think of that
of course my reaction is we know we know
you're counting on the courts
fortunately biden also knows it and
seems to be lawyering up which i've been
saying for weeks he needs to do
and then absolute last thing donald
trump made headlines with this saying if
he loses to biden he will disappear
if i lose to him i don't know what i'm
gonna do i will never speak to you again
you'll never see me again i hope that
that's a promise
that should inspire us to get out and
vote so that was
fayetteville north carolina brain
falling out nonsense from donald trump
then we will work
backwards going next to minnesota
so let's now get to donald trump's
minnesota rally on friday night
this one was bizarre and surreal
one such surreal moment was donald trump
still unaware
that ruth bader ginsburg had died starts
talking about the supreme court and you
can actually hear people in the
background yelling ginsburg is dead
people in the crowd who have heard the
news on their phone for example
you're actually going to hear as donald
trump is just sitting up there like a
fool
ranting about the supreme court you will
because it's so quiet because the crowd
doesn't know what to make of these
bizarre rants by donald trump
you can actually pick out you'll hear
two female voices about 10 seconds in
and then a male voice about 30 seconds
in yelling ginsburg is dead
totally surreal people on the stage
behind trump starting to look around
as news starts to spread and that's why
the supreme court is so important the
next president
will get one two three or four supreme
court justices i had to
many presidents have had none they've
had none because they're there for a
long time
they tend to be appointed young they're
there for a long time
but the next one will have anywhere from
one to four think of that
that will totally change when you talk
about life
when you talk about second amendment
when you talk about things that are so
important to you
you're going to be stuck for 40 years 35
years a long time
so this is going to be the most
important
election in my opinion just a surreal is
the only word i can think of to describe
this environment trump earlier in the
rally
going on an unusual screed about
how robert e lee would have won the
civil war
had it not been for gettysburg trump
outrageously praising the top
general in the fight to maintain slavery
in the united states
during the civil war and uh he was
getting beaten a lot by robert e lee
they want to rip his statue down all
over the place but robert e lee
robert e lee was a whether you like him
or not whether you like statues or not
you know they don't rip statues down
anymore assigned to law
10 years in jail
but robert e lee won many many battles
in a row
and it was supposed to be over in one
day you know it's supposed to end
immediately because the north was too
powerful
for the south but it just shows when you
have
leaders when you have a great general
and robert e lee he would have won
except for gettysburg and
that was because his general was killed
who's going to
lead gettysburg never fight uphill
me boys never fight uphill he heard they
were going uphill
stop them stop them but we had no cell
phones in that day right congressman no
cell phones
so they sent the horses to stop him stop
him but it was too late they fought
uphill and they got slaughtered
that's what happened but robert e lee
these were
incredible things and then you might
have noticed there on top of just a
ridiculous outrageous message
donald trump slurring his way through
this one as well gettysburg as you heard
there
uh trump early in the rally did some
pretty direct
racist red meat here he is talking about
whether people are enjoying having
refugees around
particularly odd because at least some
of these refugees came in during donald
trump's presidency this is part of
donald trump running on changing the
country
even though he's been president for the
last four years
one of the most vital issues in this
election
is the subject of refugees you know it
you know it perhaps better than almost
anybody lots of luck you're having a
good time with your refugees that's good
we want to have omar yeah he said omar
that's a beauty how the hell did she win
the election
how did she win
these are rallies unlike anything we've
seen
in american history outside obscure
white nationalist kkk type candidates
and
uh authoritarian dictators in the 20th
century
mostly in other countries that's what
these rallies remind me of
trump seems completely unaware that he's
the incumbent
rather than an outsider he keeps talking
as if
winning in november would be a change in
leadership he's been president for four
years
you're going to win so much and you're
going to send jason
to the u.s senate
and you're going to keep winning and
winning and winning
you're going to win on trade you're
going to win on the military you're
going to win on everything you touch
minnesota is going to keep on winning
and you're going to get tired of winning
because minnesota doesn't want to win
all the time
your football team is going to win in
the big ten they say
right now we're going to keep on winning
in minnesota and you're going to get so
tired you're going to say
jason jason please please jason
go to the president see him in the oval
office so
if if that topic is interesting to you
trump running as if someone else has
been president
check out my youtube clip from a couple
of weeks ago called trump running as if
someone else has been president
and then again donald trump raising this
idea of so-called patriotic education
it's still not totally clear what it
means but it's certainly not good
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
big deal we will teach our children to
love our country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
this continues to play on the notion
that education is some kind of left-wing
indoctrination
instead of just recognizing the reality
that the more people know how to think
the more people have critical thinking
and epistemology skills
the less likely they are to fall for the
bamboozling of donald trump and the
republican party
trump at one point urged the my pillow
guy mike lindell
to run run for governor of minnesota
just tell them i'm very unhappy
right this is what these guys are good
businessmen by the way these guys right
here mike
they might be better than you i don't
even know he may be the next governor
you know mike liddell may be
you should run you should run
that's another one of those moments
where uh trump is saying
uh let me put it this way let me put it
a different way
when trump says something this crazy 20
of what's sick is that trump is saying
it eighty percent of what's sick is that
the crowd claps
and that the crowd will go forever
anything trump says
trump then told a totally incoherent
story
the likes of which we would normally
hear from like some drunk guy at a bar
so i said to the general i said general
uh 5.7 billion billion not me billion
that sounds very hard to me general i've
bought a lot of planes in my life and a
lot of helicopters
i know a lot about it how could it be
five sir that's the best price they
could get
we only have one day to do it
i said cancel a general cancel the order
it was signed actually
yes sir i said you have the right to
cancel yes sir i do
we negotiated a great deal i said oh
good trump has this
uncanny ability to get these crowds to
be completely silent
during his strange stories in this clip
trump still seems confused about whether
stealth planes are
literally invisible to the naked eye
rather
than just being invisible to radar
they're bigger
they're more powerful they're smarter
and i like tom cruise by
the way because i mean you can't get
much better than top gun right great
movie right you can't get better i like
tom cruise but these guys are better
looking than
they got the crew cut they got the crap
under their eyes they got the whole deal
they're smart as hell so i said so
captain let me ask you how good is the
f-35 a real good sir best player we've
ever had oh great
i said uh how do you compare that with
uh what russia has
well ours is better for a specific
reason sir
you can't see it what does that mean
well when we fight they cannot see us so
we are so stealth
now that doesn't mean in three years
that it won't be obsolete because that's
what happens that's the problem with
that business
of course military equipment getting
obsolete
it's it's actually a feature of the
military industrial complex
and then trump slurred his way through
telling the crowd
that he could be living a luxurious life
right now but instead he's sitting in an
airport hangar with these people
i could right now be having a very
beautiful life of luxury and here i am
at the hangar in minnesota with
15 or 20 or 25 000.
and thousands of people that couldn't
get in and i'm working my ass off i
could be at home having a good time
wonderful time
but the one thing i say this
just complete cognitive dissonance trump
telling the crowd
i could be at my penthouse instead of
with you people
and they cheer we love trump amazing and
this isn't
all of it we will be looking after the
break at
one more rally in nevada the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so now we finish our tour of donald
trump's weekend rallies
in nevada donald trump again in this
rally raised the idea of a third
term now i want to be really clear the
reason this is notable is no longer
because donald trump really thinks he's
going to get a third term or is going to
try to get a third term he won't
this is notable because it exposes his
followers as merely sheep who care about
nothing other than getting behind trump
no matter what he says trump says fill
the
supreme court's seat sure fill it trump
says i deserve a third term
sure third term trump says we're the
best on coronavirus no matter what the
numbers say
sure we're the best on coronavirus there
is nothing they won't cheer for and here
they are cheering for donald trump's
suggestion
of a third term naturally slurring his
way through the speech
and 52 days from now we're going to win
nevada
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
and then after that we'll negotiate
right because we're probably
based on the way we were treated we're
probably entitled to another four after
that
and it should never happen to another
president it's just
a dishonest group of people but here we
are
and we're gonna be here so that's the
notable thing that the crowd cheers
even if you like this guy which already
signals a problem
if you believe in the basics of the
united states
don't you have to boo the suggestion of
a third term because a third term is
fundamentally not what this country is
about
we revere george washington for saying
term limits president not a king but
don't worry guys it's just a joke right
well either way
the fact that he keeps repeating it
without a hint of sarcasm is a problem
but what should really scare us is that
the crowd cheers
trump then went on to say that the
biggest problem the country has right
now
is the media not the coronavirus
pandemic not an unhinged lunatic in the
white house
not any of the other problems we
actually have it's the media
it's hurting our country it's hurting
our country
the biggest problem that this country
has is the fake news media
worse than the democrats because you
know the democrats and their partners
they played together joe biden
spent the last 47 years selling out
america offshoring your jobs
and then trump continuing to slur just
very labored speech calls joe biden a
pathetic human being
if trump was someone that tried to talk
to you at a bar
you would sidle over to the opposite
side of the bar
to china and you haven't seen the last
of it
[Applause]
sleepy joe biden surrendered you know
where he is now
he's in his damn basement again
no he's in his basement
he's in his basement but you know i can
be bad to him because he put the most
vicious ad on television that i've ever
seen
do you know what i'm talking about where
i'm standing
over the graves of our fallen warriors
our fallen heroes
these are great people the greatest
people there are
and i'm standing over there and they
have some sleazebag reporter from a
third rate magazine having some source
quoting me
saying i won't even use the term but
saying bad things
and there's nobody that loves our
military respects it and the people more
than me
and they took
and i didn't even ask we had 25 people
that were witnesses that are on the
record already that have said that never
took place
fox news fox news by the way instead of
covering the trump rally when this was
going on
they ran a segment on the impact of
singing happy birthday
on the transmission of coronavirus with
a bunch of panelists i don't recognize
other than
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas
dave rubin that's how bad this was
that that's what fox news was talking
about trump then
uh continues to repeat this i don't even
know where this came from
this idea that joe biden wants to ban
energy just ban it all together and then
we got hit with the plague the china
plague
and we're not uh we're not thrilled it's
a disgrace nobody should have died
nobody should have died we got hit the
whole world got hit
but they stopped it from going into the
rest of china
they stopped it from going into china
but they didn't stop it from coming into
the u.s and europe
and 188 countries
so whether or not we allow
biden to impose the biggest tax increase
in the history of our country four
trillion dollars
or ban air he wants to ban energy of ben
america
he wants to stop fracking hey by the way
completely ridiculous of course ban
energy but
stopping fracking sounds pretty good i
hope joe biden will stop
fracking if he becomes president and
then donald trump apparently not getting
a strong enough reaction to that
scaling up the unhinged claims about joe
biden
saying if biden gets elected there will
be countless deaths from suicide
and tr and biden will permanently
destroy the lives
and dreams of tens of millions of
americans
if he got in we would have the greatest
depression
in the history of our country i mean it
i think 1929 would look like good times
all right
because he'd do everything wrong he'd
raise your taxes he'd raise the hell out
of interest rates he'd do everything
wrong
the biden shutdown will permanently
destroy the lives and dreams of tens of
millions of americans
inflict totally lasting harm on our
children and lead countless deaths
from suicide don't forget when you do
these shutdowns your state is shut down
you got a governor you're shut down
there really aren't words to describe
how absurd
all of this is policy analysis
forget about it even coherent criticisms
of his opponent
forget about it even an accurate
presentation of the facts
from which he can make his unhinged
attacks forget about it
and then last clip i challenge you
make sense of this rant about antifa
i dare you to do it take a listen and
with that comes tremendous crime
and you know i was being i was talking
the other day
darling somebody just moved next door
who is it it's
a representative of antifa she will look
at her husband say
darling we're out of here we're out of
here
antifa remember they were trying to
blame uh other people they don't like to
mention the name antifa
i said it's antifa and i was right i was
right they're bad people
and you know what they have to pay a
price for the damage and for the
horror that they've caused they have to
pay a price
and it's so easy what is he
even talking about the rallies will
continue
this week we will have coverage of some
of them
not healthy to watch too much of this
stuff i will have coverage of some of
them
live on youtube twitch and facebook
okay um it was not just rallies that
donald trump did this weekend
he was also interviewed by fox news's
mark levin now if you don't know who
mark levin is
he's almost like a protege of sean
hannity if you can imagine
as propagandistic and perverse
and depraved as sean hannity is
mark levin is a guy that hannity for
years
referred to as the great one the
interview
was arguably as disconnected from
reality
as any interview donald trump has
previously done after donald trump went
on a completely
absurd rant about water mark levin tells
him you know what i like about you
you're not an ideologue
irony is dead it's dead take a look you
would have so much water in california
you'd be able all those fields that are
open i mean i've never seen that you're
driving down the highway and
everything's
like really terrible looking and then
you'll have this gorgeous patch of
green that's the only area they have the
water they're allowed like this tiny
amount of water
that whole thing could be farmland but
they send the water out into the pacific
ocean
you know it's a long story but there are
many many stories like that
the stupidity of it all i listen to you
in these different areas
you're not an idiot it's common sense
can you imagine seeing donald trump
attack people on the left
who aren't even in charge for everything
from not raking forests
to not giving trump enough water
pressure to flush his toilets why trump
needs to flush 10 to 15 times i don't
know
and then saying you know what i like
about you is you're not
ideological i have no idea
how this next comment makes sense donald
trump seemingly talking about chicago
and then jumps right into afghanistan
it's almost like
the the it is a verbal inkblot i think
is the right term look at chicago where
58 people were shot this isn't like
where there was a fighter this is was
shot
right shot and they now the reports are
58 people were shot this weekend in
chicago 10 died okay let's get on to the
weather how's the weather
they've gotten almost used to it 58
people
so we're pulling out of afghanistan as
you know we're very close to getting out
does anybody see the connection media
coverage of 58
people shot in chicago is related to
pulling out of afghanistan is this adult
adhd
is it cognitive decline is it ignorance
is it panic
and then trump continuing his brutal
assault on water
on and on and on now going on about a
massive valve
and mark levin just sits there nodding
like this makes sense
trump also talking about a very small
fish and yet they have they have no
water
and they're going to ration for
everybody
and all they have to do is let the water
come down you know what they do with the
water
they send it out into the pacific ocean
they have this massive valve
up north and as the water comes
pouring down from the snow and all
beautiful nice clean water
they send it out because there's a tiny
little fish
that they're trying to save that's doing
very poorly by the way i think it's a
spelt
tiny little fish doing very poorly doing
much worse now without the water i mean
i don't know you know
you think you do better with the water
but they have this massive valve
and they turn this massive takes a whole
day to turn it
and all that water comes and it comes
pouring and you know where it goes into
the pacific
but kevin mccarthy sees me says do you
think you could work on the water we
can't get any water for the farms
the the rantings of a madman truly then
trump began
raising the topic of explosive trees so
let's just look i just left as you know
california i met with the governor
and he and and honestly he's been
very nice with the words and that's good
do you think that after the
interview is over mark levin says
what the hell happened what what on
earth was donald trump talking about
because mark levin
is a horrible ideologue but he's not an
idiot
in the way that donald trump is does
mark levin get it do you think
at one point the topic of trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
came up
and trump said if it were up to bolton
we'd be in world war 5 right now
john bolton was a very stupid person
if i listened to john bolton we'd be in
world war 5 right now
i guess in this imaginary nightmare
trump would be responsible for world
wars 3 and 4
but bolton would have gotten us into
world war 5. and then mark levin just
nodding nodding nodding as if this makes
sense
and then speaking of people trump used
to work with trump again
referenced people being fired like dogs
i disagree with mattis very much
he was fired by president obama he was
fired
like a dog he was fired does donald
trump know what dogs are
we know trump doesn't relate to his
children normally my guess is trump
wouldn't relate to dogs normally either
what is fired like a dog even mean and
then
last one trump the victim here is poor
trump
whining to mark levin like mark levin is
his mommy
about how everybody treats him so
unfairly
uh the washington post is is a disaster
you can't get a good story it's it's
disgusting
and then you go to abc nbc probably is
the worst of all comcast i call it
comcast
not comcast it's a con job because they
always try and protect their name like
how
legitimate they are nbc is horrible cbs
is a disaster and then you go into the
the real beauty is that
msdnc as we call it and
of course cnn but at least cnn you know
where they're coming from you know
they're stone cold dishonest
at least you know that so it's a uh
it's a sad thing i mean it's a very sad
thing i fortunately local press is
extremely good i get
great local whenever i suffer a speech i
do one or two local reporters
these are the greatest stories it's like
unbelievable they
cover it so good actually they're
they're almost
uh more enthusiastic than i am and
so we have that we have some
honest media a fox is is good but fox is
not what it was i'll be
very honest with you i don't know they
become politically correct you know they
think it's wonderful they have more
democrats on than they have
practically than they have republicans
i'm complaining about it all the time
you know
with all of that being said we're doing
much better than we did four years ago
tough being a billionaire president of
the united states right you're just it's
just
everybody treats you so poorly really a
tough situation
for donald trump these interviews are of
real bonafide sociological
value propaganda value it's not
journalism
but hugely relevant for propaganda
studies
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
this caller asks a very relevant
question take a listen
hey david um i was just wondering
whatever
happened to that conga line of bad
hombres that were supposed to come to
america and
rape and kill us all or whatever i
haven't heard about them
in a while right what happened to
to all of that because that seems to
have disappeared
weird yep yeah so of of course the the
that's the immigrant caravan the migrant
caravan
um it was a big deal leading up to the
2018 midterms then we just didn't hear
about it again
they might bring it back up but as you
know donald trump doesn't like to cause
panic
so because trump doesn't like to cause
panic
i'm sure he wouldn't do something like
fear-mongering about a supposed
immigrant caravan right he would never
do because he doesn't want to cause
panic just like he didn't want to cause
panic
about coronavirus yeah now i'm gonna
punch myself in the face
today's bonus show we will be talking
about what the hell happened during the
david pakman show vacation
don't miss it become a member instantly
at joinpacman.com
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches
but making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you fifteen
percent off when you go to
davidpakman.com
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put that link
down below underneath the video